in light of reasons and tragic events
and current events I was told by people
on the internet him through your shows
in Tennessee don't go to Tennessee
lizzo took to the stage in Tennessee
over the weekend performing alongside
some fear strag performers many of which
hail from the drag race franchise
grooving along to her hit song
everybody's gay the ACT is being praised
as a protest of the recent anti-drag
legislation
being the incredible Ally that she is
lizzo put it short and sweet as to why
she was determined to come perform in
Tennessee despite the new legislations
why
why not
[Music]
[Applause]
you're added why would I not create a
safe space in Tennessee where we can
celebrate drag entertainers and
celebrate our differences and celebrate
fat black women she then thanked the
people of Tennessee who are fighting for
equality and giving hope so thank you so
much
and holding the people accountable who
should be protecting us
posting to Instagram lizzo shared her
love for the drag performers who joined
her on stage writing thank you to these
beautiful drag queens for showing their
pride in Tennessee
[Music]